helau
detroit
[Musik]
detroit hat konkurs angemeldet so ist
die größte stadt der usa die bankrott
geht
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich wie ich als junger
hier mit meinen freunden gespielt aber
heute leben wir in einem
katastrophengebiet
[Musik]
es tut weh zu sehen wie die treue hält
es ist scheiße wir leben in armut
geburts und grabstätte des kapitalismus
wie es so weit kam und wie es sich im
niedergang lebt davon erzählt dieser
film
[Musik]
eigentlich ist jack rabbit längst
pensioniert und sein rheuma quält ihn
dennoch ist der täglich mit seinem
abschleppwagen unterwegs und das hat mit
dem bankrott von detroit zu tun
die polizeiwache meinem quartier heute
geschlossen seit er wird mir
eingebrochen
also fahre ich betreue und was machen
wir jetzt wir untersuchen den fall eines
gestohlenen fahrzeug check war für ihr
selber polizist nun ist er ehrenamtlich
als ein mann bürgerwehr unterwegs ein
nachbar hat ihn auf dieses auto
aufmerksam gemacht er will die fahrzeug
seriennummer der polizei melden damit
sie es beschlagnahmen
irgendwann sehen wir kaum schon was ist
denn jetzt los hat der ex polizist etwa
angst du kannst hier nicht herum trödeln
wir wissen nicht ob jemand im haus ist
und uns etwas antun will
nicht nur der polizist hat angst zwei
drittel der einwohner sind in den
letzten 60 jahren weggezogen detroit
heute eine geisterstadt
und wo fast niemand mehr steuern bezahlt
gibt es auch fast keine polizei mehr
dafür durchschnittlich mehr als einen
mord pro tag
der wilde westen
[Musik]
jack hat den obdachlosen chemie und
dessen freund in das leer stehende haus
gegenüber seinem einquartiert die
geschichte dieses hauses zeigt den
typischen teufelskreis der besitzer wird
arbeitslos er kann die hypothek nicht
mehr bezahlen zwangsräumung obdachlose
ziehen ein
es gibt kein licht keinen strom niemand
möchte niemand zahlt steuern
ich bin ein hausbesetzer aber das ist ja
es ist illegal
aber ich bewache das haus ich schaue
dass sie niemand rein kommt ich bin so
etwas wie ein haus sitter er bewache des
haares vor dieben und drogensüchtigen
die alles was sie in die finger kriegen
zu geld machten für die heizung etwa
kriege man 15 dollar
einmal kann welche die wolken den
kühlschrank klauen
ich musste also schauen dass ich sie los
werde zeigen wie ich schlag auf den dieb
ein dreht ihn mit den füßen und schaue
was willst du in meinem haus ich habe es
nicht so gemeint
[Musik]
mit ihrem niedergang hat die stadt auch
die hautfarbe gewechselt
heute sind 80 prozent von detroit
einwohnern schwarz ich bin einer der
ganz wenigen weißen die noch in dieser
gegend leben
ich fühle mich wie ein dinosaurier ich
bin vom aussterben bedroht meine straße
erinnert mich an ein kriegsgebiet
ich war in vietnam aber hier sieht
schlimmer aus als auf den
schlachtfeldern auf denen nicht wahr
dabei waren das mal gepflegte häuser der
mittelklasse das kleine paradies nennt
er die paar quadratmeter rasen vor
seinem haus das nachbarhaus ein
drogenumschlagplatz während jahren der
diele im haus ermordet
rick sagt es so beiläufig als würde er
über hundefutter reden kommt rein
nachdem der dealer ermordet wurde hat
jemand das haus abgebrannt
wir wissen nicht ob er beweise
vernichten wollte aber das passiert oft
in detroit ein schlechter film ist
besser aus das sie nur kann man in
dieser umgebung leben
du wirst abgehärtet du siehst den
zerfall jeden tag irgendwann stört er
dich nicht wenn du abends ins bett gehst
wirst du schüsse aber das steckst du weg
du gewöhnst dich einfach daran
kann man hier
die verbrannte stadt 1967 schwarze
bewohner legen feuer
sie protestieren gegen diskriminierung
und armut erst die nationalgarde kann
den aufstand niederschlagen
43 tote über 1000 verletzte
die meisten weißen einwohner sind danach
weggezogen nightflight sagen sie hier
weiße flucht geblieben sind die armen
und die schwarzen
es ist nicht so dass ich weiterhin hier
wohnen will mein ganzes leben lang habe
ich geplant ein schönes haus zu kaufen
wenn ich pensioniert bin damit ich mit
meiner frau in ruhe leben kann und damit
unsere enkel in sicherheit
es bricht mir das herz dass unser umzug
jetzt wegen dem bankrott der stadt in
frage gestellt ist
er sitzt hier fest wir sitzen fest
es geht um rix rente als pensionierter
beamter wegen des bankrotts droht eine
massive kürzung ohne rente kein neues
haus warten im ungewissen
[Musik]
viele sagen detroit ist amerika und
amerika ist detroit die innenstadt
erinnert an den erfolg von einst 1950
war detroit die reichste stadt der usa
war es ein übersteigertes
selbstwertgefühl das motto seht ihr auf
eine einzige industrie setzen wie es
heute jedenfalls ist nur noch der sitz
von general motors hier
[Musik]
und auch general motors hersteller von
chevrolet wäre tot hätten nicht
milliarden von steuergeldern den konzern
und einen kleinen teil seiner
belegschaft gerettet
arbeitsbeginn morgens um sechs sie
nennen es frühschicht in wahrheit aber
ist es kurzarbeit von den drei schichten
ist nur eine geblieben
breakchancen
die 22 jährige hat vor kurzem hier
angefangen
ich musste sechs monate warten bis ich
angestellt wurde
es gibt also eine warteliste für diese
jobs wie ja viele leute warten seit
einer ewigkeit
jetzt bauen sie den grünen wagen chevy
volts mit elektrisch aufladbare batterie
das aber nur auf druck der regierung
obama sie ihn früher das waren
benzinfressende geländewagen
sie wurden von der japanischen
kleinwagen konkurrenz buchstäblich
überrollt page hat glück im unglück der
bankrotten staat aber auf neu
angestellte bekommt sie nur noch halb so
viel lohn wie vor der staatlichen
rettung verdienst du hier mehr aus in
meinem alten job viel mehr kannst du
sagen
als anfängerin kriegst du 15 dollar 75
cent die stunde
[Musik]
aber weißt du dass es nur noch halb so
viel ist wie früher
howard der pressesprecher schaltet sich
ein interviews am förderband sind
verboten und interviews die er nicht
überwacht sowie so dass page großmutter
63 jahre alt ein arbeitsleben führt
zuerst am fließband heute ist sie für
den web-auftritt verantwortlich zu den
vielen krisen von djembe fragt dem abbau
von zehntausenden von arbeitsplätzen
fällt ihr erstaunlich wenig ein
es war schon einfacher eine stelle zu
kriegen als ich hier angefangen hatte
aber das liegt an der schlechten
wirtschaftslage wirklich nur die
wirtschaft hat gm nicht auch fehler
gemacht
fehler passieren immer aber ich würde
sagen
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll ich
hatte ein paar dinge
[Musik]
diese paar dinge führten dazu dass fast
alle autofabriken detroit heute so
ausschauen
wer erinnert sich noch an den tag die
luxuskarosse wurde hier hergestellt aber
das ist auch schon wieder ein halbes
jahrhundert her ruinen pornografie sagen
viele eltern haben es die packard fabrik
sein zuhause
ich hatte ein bisschen angst her zu
kommen was meinen truck steige ich nicht
aus kürzlich wurden hier mehrere autos
gestohlen
es kam im fernsehen ich schaue nicht
fern davon kriegst du nur einen
hirntumor
willst du nicht auch mitkommen und die
fabrik anschauen
ich bleibe hier so viel zur paranoia ein
polizist der angst hat seinen wagen zu
verlassen
[Musik]
willkommen in meiner höhle
es gibt leute die sagen der niedergang
detroits sei ihr glück leute wie allen
früher alkoholiker zwei scheidungen erst
seit er hier lebe feier zur ruhe
gekommen es ist ein segen
ich habe jetzt ein bisschen mehr zeit
für mich hier kann ich mich auf das im
leben konzentrieren was wirklich wichtig
ist
du musst nicht dem dollar nach rennen
du brauchst keine kreditkarte und musste
ich nicht und die bude kommen
[Musik]
wer schon verfüge über ein reich von 16
hektar es ein hausbesetzer rp zahle
steuern wasser und elektrizität und in
der regel funktioniere der strom auch
dies ist der beste ort der welt hast du
auch eine waffe ich habe waffen und das
benutzte das messer
ich habe es nur zu meiner beruhigung ich
sage ja dies ist der friedlichste ort
der welt das neueste zum bankrott von
detroit hunderte von pensionierten
beamten demonstrieren heute vor gericht
die banken wurden vom staat gerettet uns
lässt man fallen die goldenen jahre des
ehemaligen feuerwehrmanns sind in gefahr
die pensionskassengelder der beamten
sollen gekürzt werden
ich bin bei der in vietnam noch bei der
feuerwehr gestorben aber die stadt
detroit will mich jetzt umbringen
aber sie alle verantworten den bankrott
sie haben politiker gewählt die sie
großzügig entlöhnten überschüsse in der
pensionskasse wurden den bergen stets
als bonus ausbezahlt
nicht die boni sollten uns beschäftigen
sondern die frage warum unser
bürgermeister so viel verdient er ist
einer der best bezahlten der usa und der
ex-bürgermeister qual micro patrick hat
sowieso alles gestohlen was wir hatten
mit patrick wird 71 jahre alt sein wenn
er aus dem gefängnis kommt er wurde
verurteilt wegen organisierten
verbrechen bestechung und steuerbetrug
[Musik]
noch gehören rick und seine frau brenda
zur mittelklasse die großeltern leben
von monatlich 5000 dollar aus rex
pensionskasse eine ahv hat er nicht
brender leidet an allergien ihre
medikamente sind sehr teuer
mit den angedrohten kürzungen werden
ihnen monatlich nur noch 1000 dollar
bleiben konstatiert an die medikamente
noch leisten
nein was wärst du tun vermutlich
dahinsiechen ich bin verängstigt aber
ich verdränge ist sonst bin ich nur noch
ein wrack stirbt detroit einen langsamen
tod ausgerechnet detroit die
geburtsstätte des kapitalismus
nein detroit liegt im land des
amerikanischen traums und downtown
detroit jetzt reanimiert
ich zeige euch ein paar unglaubliche
dinge es gibt die vorstellung von
detroit und es gibt die realität
ich zeige euch jetzt die realität seine
aufgabe firmen und bewohner nach detroit
zu locken im auftrag eines
milliardenschweren investoren der die
innenstadt aufkauft detroit aus dessen
sicht ein riesen monopoly zum glück geht
man wolkenkratzer zu schnäppchenpreisen
als erstes haben wir diese ehemalige
bank gekauft für 8 millionen
das heißt 100 dollar pro quadratmeter
die investoren interessieren sich nur
für die aufwertung des stadtzentrums
detroit aber ist hundertmal größer
alan jay krieg und alle anderen wohnen
in den aussenquartieren was sagen sie
den leuten außerhalb des zentrums die
fragen warum wir nicht bei uns
investiert wir glauben dass die stärkung
der innenstadt sich automatisch auf die
quartiere außerhalb auswirkt das dürfte
noch ein weilchen dauern
das ist detroit ganz unten tiefer als
diese obdachlosen kannst du nicht sinken
die polizei kann die zeit nicht retten
der arzt nicht die kirche nicht der
einzige der uns jetzt noch helfen kann
ist jesus jesus detroit gerettet hat
überleben sie hier dank drogendeals und
hilfsorganisationen
das ist gift bis vor kurzem wie er sagt
er habe bis 20.000 dollar pro monat
verdient ich habe ein haus für meine
mutter gekauft
ich bin 27 jahre alt und weiß alles vom
leben ehrlich leute sind meinen namen
gestorben und von hier stammen die
millionen die der investor in die
innenstadt punkt sie alle verkaufen
hypotheken per telefon auf
massengeschäft eine top chance für junge
detroit nur die schulen in detroit sind
katastrophal
die hälfte der die troika hat mühe beim
lesen anschneiden
ist es nicht ein problem für sie
andauern desto auf jeden fall
es ist eine herausforderung die wir
meistern müssen wir bringen unseren
leuten darum unsere firmenkultur bei wir
setzen auf light sprüche zum beispiel
auf diesen hier besessen davon eine
bessere lösung zu finden
[Musik]
giften besucht seinen onkel und wer sich
fragt ob es diesen nicht stört dass sein
neffe krieg verkauft hat stellt die
falsche frage
ich bin ein herr in st
weil ich keinen job findet bin ich
gezwungen kriminell zu sein und meine
sucht zu finanzieren
alles handtaschen stehlen und häuser
einbrechen autos klauen
[Musik]
in diesem hause habe ich die drogen
verkauft um für meine familie zu sorgen
die fing an als ich 13 war und diese
19-jährige sagt sie heiße britney und
giften sei ihre große liebe zu sein
unter drogen dealern aufgewachsen und
das ist noch lange nicht alles
mein bester kollege wurde erschossen
ich stand neben ihm zum glück wurde ich
nicht getroffen
als der schuss fiel war ich
blutüberströmt und ich sah dass sie
meinem kollegen die hälfte des gesichts
weg geschossen hatten
mein kollege war in einer gang
es war vermutlich eine abrechnung in den
kreis alltagsgeschichten in detroit wie
viel schlimmer kann es noch werden
lass dich nicht töten
im sommer ist er sein basketball platz
was würden sie mir raten wenn ich sage
hier ist es schön aber detroit ist die
stadt mit der höchsten mordrate der usa
die arbeitslosigkeit liegt bei 20
prozent die stadt des bankrotts warum
soll ich hier investieren
schon wieder ein mord sie war 19 jahre
alt
[Musik]
was immer ich kenne den vater des
ermordeten mädchens
ich bin mit ihm zusammen aufgewachsen
und bernd bürger wenn man tag um fassung
ringt sehen sich rentner weg zurück zum
detroit seiner kindheit der
erfolgreichen amerikanischen stadt und
mit jeder abgerissenen hausruine wächst
ihre hoffnung auf ein neues detroit auf
die wiedergeburt der einst so
bewunderten weltmacht amerika
[Musik]